the world health organization's estimate
of close to 15 million global deaths due
to covet 19 is nearly three times the
official death count of just under five
and a half million as reported by
governments
the who says it used statistical
modeling to arrive at the expanded
number which includes deaths directly
from covid and from other medical
conditions that went untreated due to
the pandemic strain on health systems
this is extremely important information
for anyone to have especially policy
makers and the public we need to know
the true toll of the pandemic we have to
remember that behind these numbers are
people according to the who's report
covet-related deaths in india were
nearly 10 times higher than the official
count indian health officials pushed
back against the report thursday
attacking the who's use of statistical
modeling please appreciate that these
kind of assumptions to be used for a
nation of our size of a continent size
and to put us in poor light is not
desirable other countries with large
discrepancies include pakistan where
according to the w-h-o excess deaths
were eight times higher than the
official kovid death count
in egypt it was 12 times higher
and in mexico it was double i think um
the experts all along uh were very aware
of the uh let's say shortcomings or
tools that were not available right from
the beginning so
um the amount of testing etc would mean
that there were many deaths that went
unaccounted for
the wh says most of the excess deaths
were concentrated in southeast asia
europe and the americas and were in
middle income countries they also
confirmed the global death toll was
higher for men who accounted for 57
percent of deaths
the who is the first to caution that its
report on global coveted related deaths
is an estimate and thus imperfect but
the agency says it is nevertheless
important to get an accurate accounting
of the pandemic's toll to better prepare
for future threats
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington